Let me set the scene for people.
Please.
Because if nothing else,
I'm a setter of scenes, a scene setter,
if you will.
(Sona sighs)
I paint a picture, a mind picture.
We are here at Gourley's lovely home
and I'm gonna say there's a little bit
of a Mr. Miyagi in the original
"Karate Kid" vibe here.
Well, that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me.
No, but like, it's a nice, there's a,
we're in Pasadena and let me just begin
by saying I got in my car to come here
and I plugged in your address.
And Waze said it was gonna
be an hour and 28 minutes.
Oh.
To get here.
And then Waze started saying
are you sure you want to go there?
(Gourley and Sona laughing)
And I was saying to Waze,
"Well, he's my friend and
we're doing a podcast."
And then Waze was like, "Wait a minute,
isn't your name on the podcast?"
"Why aren't they doing it at your house?"
I don't know how Waze
has all this information.
Yeah, I'm not sure I understand that.
Did it take you first
to Santa Monica Airport
and try to fly you here?
It took me to Catalina.
Yeah.
(Gourley and Conan chuckling)
It took me 15 minutes.
Yes, well, that's the thing is--
It was nice for me.
First of all,
I applaud both of you
because you've made a very bold choice
to raise your children in another country.
(Gourley and Sona laughing)
I don't know where we are
but I'm not sure we're
in the United States anymore.
It took me a long, long time to get here.
Come on.
No, look,
I know people accuse someone like me
of being in some sort of entitled bubble.
Yeah.
[Gourley] Yeah.
And I have looked into,
to be fair, having a
bubble built around me.
A literal bubble?
(Gourley and Sona laughing)
There's, I guess there's a zoning issue.
But I wanted, I wanted an
actual bubble until people--
You went to the permitting office?
I went to the permitting office
and they said, "Sir what you're talking
about is a big bubble that surrounds you."
And I said, "Yes, I don't
care what it costs."
"I have the money, I just
wanna live inside a bubble."
"And I have this company
that's gonna build it
for me called Entitle Co."
(Sona laughing)
And then someone said,
"It's gonna look bad."
I didn't understand why.
But anyway, it was, but once you get here
and I do say once you get here
and you've changed your currency
and had all the requisite
shots, it is lovely.
This is beautiful.
It's beautiful.
You know what, it took me
no time at all to get here.
I came earlier with my boys
to play with your daughter.
Yeah.
Then I went home
and then I came back,
probably all in the time
that it took you to get here.
But it was really nice
and convenient, and easy.
I had several children
on the way over here.
(Sona laughing)
Two of them, you know,
it's like transatlantic
travel in the 1780s.
One of them didn't make it.
He got the seagull sickness.
(Sona laughing)
(Gourley chuckling)
But no, it's really nice because again,
I will paint the picture,
we're in a lovely backyard.
And Gourley, I know this about you,
you have excellent taste.
You have very good, he's
got very good taste.
He does.
And he's very handy.
And he's built this wonderful oasis.
And we're sitting in the backyard.
We've got this lovely
Solo Stove in front of us.
That's burning Juniper wood.
Can you smell that?
It smells really good.
[Gourley] Oh, it smells so good.
And I will say, I know there are people
that are like, "Why is Conan
just mentioning Solo Stove?"
Solo Stove, maybe we're doing business
with them, maybe we aren't.
That's not the important thing.
We are.
That's a great--
Yeah, there's Solo Stoves everywhere.
I feel like they sent you like, four?
They sent five and they sent
mm, a small forest worth of wood.
(Sona laughing)
Yeah.
The Solo Stove though, is
burning very efficiently
and wonderfully in front of us.
And I only mention it not
because they are a sponsor.
That's not, but I do love a fire.
Oh, it's the best.
I love a fire.
And I know that if I was in some sort
of industrial accident,
if my arm caught fire,
if people tried to put it out,
I'd say, "Let's just watch it for a bit."
(Gourley laughing)
That's how much I love a fire.
I thoroughly enjoy
sitting around a campfire
and I can't wait to use this.
They gave me one.
[Sona] Yeah.
I'll just say it.
And the only problem is
if I get this bubble built
around my house, the
smoke's gonna collect.
Luckily, there's not much smoke.
Well, that's, Sona,
funny you bring that up,
but it's true, there's
not much, not much smoke
when you get a, it's ingenious.
But listen, maybe Solo Stove
will come up later, maybe they won't.
Who knows?
Right.
It's one of the great mysteries
of this wonderful outdoor
adventure we're having.